all right Ashley Yeah Ashley uh where
you from originally
I was born in the Dallas Fort Worth area
in Texas
tell me about your family growing up
um
my dad used to be a drug addict
and my mom
what and he was like he was he was
that sticks out most of my mind because
like he wouldn't be around uh like a
whole lot and it'd be because like he
was on drugs or he was in in rehab
um my mom was like very loving and
I was I was in love not like in a
romantic way but I was in love with my
mom
um she was and she was very very
sweet to me
for
for the like
for the most part how would you describe
your childhood in general
my childhood in general
um
confusing in that I can't recall it in
chronological order in anyone like
attempt to like
um reflect on what my life has been thus
far
but no no abuse nothing crazy going on
well uh I mean like what would you
consider abuse
like physical abuse
psychological
um
sexual abuse anything like that
like
um so yeah there there was I mean there
there was some like you know I used to
get hit with a wooden spoon
on uh like on the butt if I like didn't
listen to my mom or something like that
um and I was like hit on like the back
of my thighs or like my butt uh with a
her belt sometimes
um
like one time one time she um heard me
talking about like um like heard me
talking about like
oral sex
um to my friend who is spending the
night and because she was listening at
the door and um and then like when I was
done with the story I was telling my
friend she opens the door and she was
like I she's like
I think this is the uh the last time
we're spending the night something like
that like all crazy and she called me
into the hallway and she shoved a bar of
soap in my mouth like and it busted my
lip like because I guess my lip was in
the way and then she grinded it back and
forth and like wouldn't let me get water
or spit it out and um it'll slap me in
the face and then take a picture of me
telling me um
uh
like so that my dad
okay but that was without the same no
okay never mind that was a different
night the picture thing was a different
night she wanted to send my dad in Texas
pictures of what his daughter has become
you know because I had I had a spaghetti
strap tank top and um and the strap fell
down
and she's and like I wasn't supposed to
wear that and the fact I was wearing it
was wrong but the strap falling down and
being seen like that was was even worse
and so um
she and it would be worse than my dad's
eyes she felt so she like pulled the
strap back down before she took the
picture
and like I mean stuff like that
what were you like in high school
in high school I was like I was like
weird
yeah
drugs came into the picture at some
point drugs came in the picture like
um well I started doing drugs when I was
12. but then I was locked up out of
state in like
um behavioral emotional treatment
centers
so I didn't continue doing I started
myself but I didn't continue doing them
until I was like 16.
um
I was weird in high school because I had
been in those treatment centers out of
state doing therapy for like years and
um
I was on psych meds and
my mom was a tyrant
and my life was depressing
because I wasn't allowed to have a
boyfriend
but I've always felt a sense of like
being in love with somebody
and so
and I couldn't wear the clothes I wanted
to wear so it was just like really a
[__] up time for me I would cry I
would like many times I would I would I
would just like lay in bed and cry about
having to um go to school the next day
and I wouldn't have to go
because I would cry so much was it a
religious upbringing
um
I see a lot of like religious tattoos on
your
on your forehead and your stomach
yeah it was a religious upbringing my
mom uh
uh or anti-religious tattoos I should
say well I consider my tattoos religious
um because the word religious does not
um exclusively belong to the mainstream
or or you know uh right-hand path
religions and um so my religion is a
left-hand path religion and
um I'm I'm very religious I'm extremely
extremely religious but the sense of the
word religious may sound kind of like
strange when you people people associate
religious with holy and um depending on
how you mean holy also like the word
holy actually means like like a whole a
healthy
in a sense of like a whole like um in
like a physiological sense if you were
to look at it like
etymologically speaking
um from the in the Norse language which
is like I I have like studied some of
you know Norse culture and
um for my religious reasons so yeah you
could say I'm I'm uh religious in a holy
way like if you were gonna intend it
like that but not in like a sacrament of
Christ's way no but what do the upside
down
crosses represent
um Satan
yeah I was out yeah you have a big Satan
tattoo on your arm too yeah I do I have
that Satan right there and then I have
um you have some 666 and stuff like that
666 Lucifer
right there
and um uh Rose Tattoo and then I have um
Satan right here
and um and then that says chaos and
runes and like chaos isn't is um another
name for Satan
and then Loki
is also another name for
Satan so are those tattoos a little more
in line with what you believe and Satan
right here
yeah
um
absolutely yeah I I love Satan
and what do you love about Satan
um
like
ah it's like such a it's just like it's
like an easy question to answer but then
it's like usually when someone asks me
that like I'll uh sometimes I'll sit and
I'll try to explain it to them but um
like as of late I'll hit him with a like
what do you love about your [__] mom
like what do you love about the person
your significant other and can you give
me their social security number and
their [__] direct message like and
can I see that [__] tonight or what's
up like you want to tell me where she
works and what she was wearing this
morning like what else do you want to
know without doing the own your own
[__] like like like way to like know
it you know I mean like people want I'm
not I'm not saying you it's like people
will be wanting to know like the let me
just get the gist of it like can I get
can I get the [__] like pot of gold
at the end of the rainbow I don't give a
[__] about the rainbow or like the trip
there or how to get or what it what it
means just can I get the goal just tell
me the steps I got to do I don't I don't
care about what it means you know or
like like almost like identity theft and
[__] like that um
I love Satan because I I I I don't even
know how to describe it like
is my love like a um
I mean it I think definitely the fact
that I I love Satan so much is like
probably a stumbling block for uh for
people that would otherwise not end up
going down the path that they end up
going down after they meet me
and I'm okay with that like I'm I'm good
with that
that I think that would be their fault
for
you should stop at the name Satan you
know what I mean if I'm saying I love
Satan well she said love okay but I said
Satan
so we're like why are you so you're like
you still proceed you should be you
should be going the other way you know
um
yeah what is your drug now
my drug no what do you mean what is my
drug now like you said you started you
started using drugs when you're a teen
young teen okay yeah I'm a little bit
paranoid see so that's why I was like I
forgot that I had said that and I'm like
what do you mean now like what do you
know about me from before okay just
because I was wondering
um I do crystal meth Crystal
methamphetamines I smoke it yeah yeah
what does it do for you
um
it does a lot for me and
I don't feel like
able to like think or feel
or have ideas or um
or be like
um
like truly alive like or or motivated
without crystal meth it like I believe
Chris the old Crystal Method is and um I
know it to be sorcery
so
um I I know that it's part of my
religion and I know that it's part of my
relationship with Satan
and
yeah
um I think I think because I was forced
to take psych meds also within those
adolescent years I was forced to take a
lot of heavy psychiatric meds and um I
think that like
messed something up in me that it
wouldn't have been messed up you know to
where like I don't have that like they
robbed me of my natural reward system
you know like I can't
function with or without psych meds like
as a average person could function I
don't have that same like Drive
mess gives me the drive yeah
do you have children
I have given birth four times but I
don't like to say that I have children
because uh
because I don't have children they're
they've all like one is in guardianship
um and three have been adopted
and um I don't want like also so they're
so they're not mine and also like I I
really have to really like I haven't
come into like a clear
um
decision on like how I feel about how
they got here in the first place I think
it's a little a little actually a lot
[__] up
because like I I mean one person says
children I say like um like parasites
okay like I don't remember ever getting
a [__] like a a letter or a phone
call from anyone saying hey can um hi I
don't have a name yet but um anyway I'd
like to know if I can post up in your
body for like 10 months and grow
to like learn how to be a human and then
come out through the hole that you get
[__] out of you know what I'm saying
like that's [__] weird you know and
then suck on your tits and like cry and
[__] myself like you know what I'm
saying and pretend that like you know me
and like observe observe like a [__]
alien or something like no one ever
asked me that no one ever asked me hey
can I come can I come do that yeah of
course I've heard when you have sex you
know that you can get pregnant but
really I mean if the thing coming out of
me is a human that's what we're calling
ourselves right humans
if that thing is a human and has a soul
like like
what what made it ever I mean how is the
how is that okay I just I have a real
hard time with that one and then like
I'm I'm I really think I was done very
wrong I think that like it's an
Abomination like I think getting
pregnant
for me to like have
I think that was like such an
Abomination like for that to happen to
me it was horrible and I haven't even
realized the trauma of it yet
truly
what a violation something to just enter
your body
and try to form us like late so that it
could form itself as like a clone or
something
as far as I'm concerned the only thing
that children like are good for
um
or like the only thing that would make
sense as to like to have a child right
is
um like uh I don't and I don't know a
lot I speak from a place of ignorance
but like stem cells or like body parts
okay like let's say if I needed a liver
one day that would be a good reason to
have these these parasitic uh be a host
to a parasite that comes out looking
like a human because if I need liver
there you go I got like three to choose
from right and we know they're soulless
obviously so it's not like it's gonna do
anything to them like to like put them
under and take their liver out like just
do something else and I'm not a [__]
doctor but like do something else and
make their bodies keep functioning you
know or like take each part and
you know like if they would like take
science would like take each part of
their body and like put it on like
cryogenics or something so that like I
could essentially be like a healthy
Immortal that would make sense but um
that's that's what comes to my mind
it's a very interesting perspective on
pregnancy
yeah I mean I don't know why anyone else
isn't isn't isn't thinking the same way
like you don't even know this is like a
body coming out of you like a [__]
body living a body living inside your
body for for that long I don't remember
being in utero do you
I don't remember ever coming out of a
[__] vagina or living inside somebody
I and therefore I don't know if I did
since I don't know that I can't remember
it then I can't actually stand by that
and say that I was that's how I entered
the world
so yeah I think there's definitely like
some sort of weird conspiracy maybe with
that part
you've been living on the streets for
how long
I've been living on the streets for
[Music]
um
like
I mean I've gone to prison four times
I've been arrested like 60 times
um
I've had brief like interim housing
right but
for the greater part of
um
23 years
I just turned 39. hmm so for the greater
part of 23 years I've been living on the
streets
maybe not the greater part but like
about half of that
what have you been to prison for
what have I been to prison for
okay well
like over 10 years ago
um uh what's it called
possession of a controlled substance
which is what they call it if you if if
you get caught with meth okay
um possession of a controlled substance
was
um a felony in any amount like like it
could be like ten dollars worth it in
what state
in California really yeah Orange County
well I guess it's not down here in skid
row though
yes it's technically illegal but the
cops
look the other way
yeah that's bizarre to me it's two
different worlds yeah
like people people feel comfortable
enough to like sit out on the [__]
corn street corner and
and not bat an eyelash like if the
[__] cop Drives By that's crazy
um yeah I went to prison for possession
of a controlled substance it's a
misdemeanor now but when it was a felony
um I haven't placed on probation and and
got violated violated I got
when you get three violations on your
third violation you have to go to
um 16 months State Prison
or
drug court
which you get out right away but you
have all these obligations I was like
[__] hardcore and I wanted to get my
um like all my friends everyone I knew
had was already on parole and um and
like I I like respected and admired them
for the gangsters that I that I felt
they were
so this was my opportunity to like you
know
like uh get some I guess people say like
street cred or clout or something you
know so I just went ahead and I took the
um 16 months and then uh and then let's
say so that's the first two terms my
third term was for assault with a deadly
weapon
and that was a strike and then um my
fourth prison term was for assault with
Force likely to produce great bodily
injury and that was my second strike
and those were
like
the penal code is like 245 a or
something like that for assault with
Force likely likely to produce great
bodily injury
I I signed for
um
four years
at 85 percent
and the strike
that's after going to Patton State
Hospital from being declared incompetent
stand trial coming back and fighting my
case in the county for like nine months
um
another person that I know
the other person being my boyfriend who
I hate let's just have that for the
record
my boyfriend assaults me and is and is
seen it like live as it's happening by
undercover cops that were in the area
for another reason unassociated to us
and when they saw him assaulting me they
felt like according to them they felt
like it was
like serious enough to blow whatever
they were doing off and and come break
like stop that from happening right they
charged him with the same charge
you know he did he did not get a strike
um he did a total of like
eight or nine days in jail
and he has to do 52 weeks of um domestic
violence classes which he has like still
not enrolled in or anything like that
and they put a restraining order against
us like a stay away order which we've
never [__] respected and we've been
pulled over by the police like with both
our names being ran at the same time
like at least
I mean at least five times since that
happened and every time we just faint oh
what what we're shooting order and he
never gets arrested for it which I'm
glad I'm glad because like even though
he's a piece of [__] I need him around
you know
um have you been in love before I stay
in love Yeah have I been in love I've
been yeah
yeah
[Music]
it's [__] up
being in love is [__] up well what do
you consider in love
I would say having one person that you
are
deeply connected with
is it becomes very very important to you
and your well-being and
you take care of them you protect them
you
you want what's best for them
you know it's best for them
is is that the
is that the like full scope of a of your
wants when you're in love is what's best
for them
yeah
no I mean it's it's a it's a wide range
of
things that are
involved in in a loving relationship
if you have to ask what if you have to
ask these questions when I ask you if
you've Been Loved Before then the answer
is probably no
well like I mean I think I have
it's just like it's so like you know
people tell you like okay when you're
when like um
everyone has like an idea of like what
with their parents or what their family
like taught them about love
um when they were children right
I don't even know okay sidebar I don't
know if everyone was a child just like I
don't remember being in utero I didn't
watch everybody their whole life I don't
know like that like not some freak
phenomenon like I was a child once and
like yeah that might not happen to
everybody like some people might like
just like like be on earth like normally
like like adults the whole time I don't
know that's weird
what do you think about that were you
were you ever a child I was you were
okay I remember it very well
okay I believe you
okay
um and if if you ask me if I've been in
love before I know instantly the answer
is hell yes
how do you know
because it takes you up it's like a
bulldozer in your life it just you'll
never forget it
it
it's like would you say it's more pain
than pleasure
no
no because even even the pain is
pleasure is kind of almost
pleasure in a strange way
would you especially in the long run
would you describe it as like rapturous
being in love yeah yeah kind of yeah
do you do you okay
is is it is it the right thing to do
when you're in love to like
to um like excommunicate everyone else
that's in your psyche at the time that
you you decide you're in love you're
like all right
you know all the other like psychic type
of like ties like mental emotional ties
you have in your mind of like random
people are not random people may be
thinking about like are you supposed to
cut those off when you're in love you're
not supposed to do that or the opposite
but sometimes that happens when you just
become so enamored with one person and
people stop hanging out with all their
other friends who become less important
I've seen that happen
it didn't happen with me but I've seen
it happen
yeah like that that's that's what I do
that's that's what I do and then like I
expect the same thing
um
I'm not even sure that's love that could
be some kind of need
that
looks like love but actually isn't
you know what this is this is where it
gets weird it's like when did
how the [__] did something that
okay we can all agree this is like a
shoe if you want to be specific it's
like a slide it's like a sandal okay we
all know that like that's the Adidas
symbol right
we're not like over here like like like
getting real like shadowy and like like
weird like we're not murky on like
that's an Adidas symbol like because we
know what it looks like and it's an
Adidas symbol like oh [__] you know or
like wow
um rain is coming from the sky like you
know what if you know we it we don't
rain is and then we see it and we feel
it and sometimes guy it's like why is
This Love Like Love
it's interesting you know it's not
interesting it's [__] up that love is
like the thing that's like really
like
I know what it is and but
I don't know what it is like you know
what I mean it's very confusing
why is it confusing
because a lot of things are disguised as
love but they actually aren't
yeah and they take the place of it they
seem to take the place of it and they
play that role in our lives or something
that looks like it
it's a comp it's a complicated question
you always they say like God is love
right people say God is love
um
I thought God was God
I don't know if I'm gonna get to the
bottom of what love is
a quick little conversation with a girl
there's upside down cross on her
forehead there's a song by uh Eminem
called spacebound
and um
one of the in the lyrics one one of the
verses is he says um
and Love is Evil spell it backwards I'll
show you
get it like l-o-v-e-v-o-l
but like evil
sounds like evil like it sounds it
sounds kind of the same if you don't
know what the person is intending when
they're saying like evil like in
I say saying love backwards or like no
they mean evil
but um
I just know that I have more love in my
heart than
um than any Christian I've ever met or
anyone from any religion I've ever met
more of a capacity to love
but does it but that being said um
that's why I have so much hate also
um because people are so incapable of
love and accepting it they see love and
they just want to [__] it all up
you know so is this what you would tell
your four kids
oh
um
tell them like in what in what sense
like that you have so much love to give
uh like you said is this what I would
tell them like like what would be the
the setting is it like the one thing I
would tell them when was the last time
you saw your kids
okay two of them at Birth
um
the other ones so if we pulled the Jerry
Springer we brought all four of them in
here and we all sat together and you
you're going to tell them that you have
so much love to give and they're they're
gonna what do you think their reaction
would be
okay like like I would say probably like
if they said something like snotty to me
or like or like implying that like
um I don't know what love is based on
like the fact that their lack of a
relationship with me that's how I went I
would I would I would hit them with the
like
um well I have more love in my heart
than like you know than anybody I've
ever met and then they probably their
reaction would be like um
you know
um
I don't know I mean I could predict what
what the one that's with my mom what her
reaction would be but I don't know about
the the other ones
um yeah like it's like I'm not gonna
it's like that's you guys's Journey you
know like
I really don't I used to really give a
[__] if people like believe me that I
was capable of love now I'm more
concerned about like people believing me
like that I'm capable of hate and
destruction you know like because like
being the I'm Satan's Priestess like I
um
I can access things like black magic and
and and
um
and curses and do things to destroy
um people that have [__] with my love
or
or people that I just maybe I'll look at
them and I just don't like them you know
I don't even have to have a [__]
reason but really the type of
complicated individual that I am I do
have to have a reason you know otherwise
I'm not going to have the like emotional
Gusto to like like see this thing all
the way through type thing you know like
um
yeah but I think I think when I say like
I'm capable of so much love I I like at
this point in my life when I say that
like I kind of like say it because like
I kind of say it like in like in an
arrogant way like purposely arrogant
like
hoping that it knowing and hoping that's
gonna piss some people off you know
like now that I think at this time in my
life it's um
like who I am is becoming more evident
and
um
and so and and so for me to make a
statement that I did about love it
is gonna really like be a kick in the
teeth to some people you know
which is that's what I'm going for you
know not an actual kick in the teeth
I've met
you know metaphorically speaking or tell
me what happened about what happened to
your teeth oh man
well crystal meth when I when I do
Christmas I like
oh like um
a lot of people supposedly do this like
um when I start to fall asleep
or as soon as I fall asleep uh my body
will be like like twitch itself awake
right you know my body will like do a a
twitch that I'm not meaning to do
because I'm falling asleep but the
twitch it will be so hard that it wakes
me out of my sleep and I I realize oh I
had like some major twitch or the person
was will tell me I did well I've I've
succeeded past that now to where um I
don't really do the twitch anymore what
I do is like a full lunge
um I'm laughing but it's [__] up like
it's like um
okay I was sitting in a chair in the
apartment of of a associate of mine and
I fell asleep I woke up on my knees like
like uh like I don't know like at least
three feet in front of me in like uh I
heard like a big like boom sound as I
hit my knees and they also they watched
they were wide awake watching me I felt
so what the same thing was when I
knocked my teeth out I
I did a lunge like I had fallen I was
I was falling asleep no one else was
around I'm falling asleep and um as I
fell asleep I [__] I threw my my body
through itself off of the [__] bench
and
and like
as my eyes open as I was like right
before my teeth hit the ground
and that that sounds like a cover story
for like a [__] person that's getting
like beat up or something right like I
run into the doorway or like you know no
but like this is this is really real
like I do this almost all the time when
I sleep now I I [__] injure myself I
end up throwing myself out of whatever
sleeping position I'm in onto the ground
I woke up recently with a bike on top of
me
like my boyfriend put a bite like a
mountain bike upside down on it on a
dresser like a tall adjuster that's
about like about close to five feet tall
and and then and then we had an air
mattress that we we filled up right it
was it it filled the whole room there
was no more walking room that's why he
had to put the bike up on the on on the
dresser well I woke up I guess
um like after falling asleep a little
bit I woke up and um
and I don't remember standing up but I I
must have stood up
and the dresser was unsteady
and the [__]
um
it was like slow-mo as it fell and I was
I was naked in the bike I remember the
bike falling on me like I just I turned
away as it was falling and the way it
landed was like I was like this far away
from my boyfriend's face and I just I
woke him up in a
I was like bikey and he's like oh bikey
and he sees the bike like this big ass
bike on my back what's your biggest fear
now
everything
you have a lot of anxiety
I think I think of a reason to be afraid
of everything like
if I'm not afraid of if I don't have any
fear
at any given moment of the day like um
my my mind like automatically does this
thing where like
I redo the thing in my head like the
status quo and I think of a reason to be
all I was thinking of reason to be
afraid
like
uh I I don't know I don't
there's so there's so much more to be
afraid of than I've even fathomed yet
things that can happen like what
so much more to be afraid of like like
my I think my biggest no I'm not gonna
say like you you don't you don't want to
you know I don't know I might tell you
what you want but I don't think you want
to know some of my like like the biggest
fears like it's like it goes pretty deep
like I have a big imagination and like
hey try me
Okay so
this isn't my biggest fear but this is a
fear that
um
that dwell that that I dwelled on for a
minute and like if I think about it in
full capacity
um it's overwhelming to me
um okay
so
um how do I say this
um
it's a point where
there are people
who have been alive however long on this
Earth I'm gonna say older than me okay
um who have a certain hardcoreness that
I lack okay like because like there's
people who've done horrible things to me
and like I'll still
if given the opportunity I usually can't
like like
in in a like one-on-one situation you
know like put them in their place like I
can do it like magically speaking away
internally but I'm not the type that can
like I could never be something like a
dominatrix or like a
um like
um like a [__] you know an assassin
or something like that right like I'm
not good at [__] like that there are
people who are alive and that um that
are that are
good at [__] like that okay
um
and there's something that can so easily
happen should they choose to turn the
switch
um and what what that is that would that
would include all walks of life that
that would not like
I wouldn't be
um excluded from this this starting
process
okay what it what it is is like um
you know you have like Dungeons right
like uh sex dungeons and I've never been
to one I don't know and I don't want to
go to one but um my but a fear of this
real that that is like is a okay you've
seen these huge parking garages that
they have around the city they're huge
right
huge amounts of space okay
so um
imagine if one day
um like it was just a straw that broke
the camel's back or the person who
decided you know we need like
let me get this many subscribers to this
or this many hits on this this brand and
it's on I'm gonna do my thing okay
imagine like a [__] parking garage
like full of people and
and uh it what it is essentially like
it's a
it's like a worse than the Christian
Bible describes like hell that that
incurs starts with of like um because of
a lack of um like like doing life the
right way it's like constant punishment
and it's um I don't know how to describe
it but look no one would be excluded
like it's so [__] scary because like
when the moment happens it's a thing
where like when the moment happens if it
were to happen one would find themselves
as I did like when I saw this in a
vision okay one would find themselves
wanting to quickly abandon any property
they have because that's just going to
be more evidence of their [__] you
know meaning like cigarettes drugs
[__] all that extra [__] you know
um
and look in going outside and finding
that there's nowhere to go there would
be there would be like a thing where
there would be nowhere to go
a thing where you suddenly are like your
mind is
your mind your soul your body your
spirit your everything is
it's it's BL it's like it's like this
it's like blocked it can't go
it can okay it wants to go left it can
go left but it can only go left knowing
that this left is being [__] that
this left is like every move is a
mistake at this point like not a mistake
every move is a [__] it's the wrong
one you can't make a right move the only
right move to make and that would be the
most horrifying move is to go basically
turn yourself in to go to the place the
bad place and present yourself
for you know like like as if you've been
drafted you know
um knowing that that's like like that's
come on the side the signs are there
like you've been drafted you need to cut
so
and and it all in all
I mean cops like nothing and nothing can
stop it it's um they say the All-Seeing
retina
and it I mean it distinctly has to do
with the devil this is something that
couldn't happen without the devil okay
but
it would it would be so then there's no
and you couldn't talk to anyone about it
you really can't you cannot talk to any
who you who can you you can't even talk
in code about it like ever get the idea
okay it's so [__] scary it's so
[__] scary and um
I'm not scared of it anymore though
because like I I psychically connected
with the person who would be in charge
of that and and
um uh I also saw like the end game
result of like what
it
what it would be and I actually would be
um
I actually would be let away from that
because of the because of the type of
heart that I have and because of the
things that I truly want
[Music]
excellent yeah all right Ashley thank
you so much for sharing your story
you're welcome I wish you lots of luck
out here
hail Satan be careful
was that a threat no no I'm saying be
careful out here yeah
thank you